- [Narrator] This
program is a presentation
of UCTV for educational and
non commercial use only.
(happy music)
- We're gonna start
by reading a very short story by Borges.
This is probably not legal
'cause I'm gonna read you the whole story
but the whole story is only
a couple of paragraphs.
Borges and I,
yeah, I don't know whether
it's fair use or not.
Borges and I, by Jorge
Luis Borges, 1899 to 1986.
"The other one, the one called Borges,
"is the one things happen to.
"I walk through the
streets of Buenos Aires
"and stop for a moment,
"perhaps mechanically now
"to look at the arch of an entrance hall
"and the grillwork on the gate.
"I know of Borges from the mail
"and I see his name on
the list of professors
"or in a biographical dictionary.
"I like hourglasses, maps
and 18th century typography,
"the taste of coffee and
the prose of Stephenson.
"He shares these preferences
but in a vain way
"that turns them into the
attributes of an actor.
"It would be an exaggeration
"to say that ours is a
hostile relationship.
"I live, let myself go on living
"so that Borges may
contrive his literature
"and his literature justifies me.
"It is no effort for me to confess
"that he has achieved some valid pages.
"But those pages cannot save me
"because what is good belongs to no one,
"not even to him
"but rather to the
language and to tradition.
"Besides, I am destined
to perish definitively
"and only some instant of
myself can survive in him.
"Little by little, I am
giving over everything to him
"though I am quite aware
of his perverse custom
"of falsifying and magnifying things.
"Spinoza knew that all things
"long to persist in their being,
"the stone eternally wants to be a stone
"and the tiger a tiger."
Why am I laughing at a great
philosopher like Spinoza?
Well, I don't know.
"I shall remain in Borges, not in myself
"if it is true that I am someone.
"But I recognize myself less in his books
"than in many others
"or in the laborious
strumming of a guitar.
"Years ago I tried to free myself from him
"and went from the
mythologies of the suburbs
"to the games with time and infinity.
"But these games belong to Borges now
"and I shall have to imagine other things.
"Thus my life is a flight
"and I lose everything and
everything belongs to oblivion
"or to him.
"I do not know which of
us has written this page."
So that's the story.
Now, Jorge Luis Borges
is definitely the author
of this short story,
the one who wrote it,
presumably edited it
over a period of time,
published it and who was
similarly responsible
for all the other works we know by Borges.
I will call him the author.
Then there are two characters in it.
There's the one the author
calls and I will call Borges
and there's the other one
who I will call the writer
and the writer is referred to in the story
in the first person
that is with the word I in
the English translation.
In the story, the writer
and Borges are presented
as the same person.
The writer is a famous
author named Borges,
although he's curiously alienated
from this aspect of himself
and so writes as if
Borges were someone else.
But the point of the story would be lost
if the writer were not Borges.
Borges could've written a story like this
about some other author,
real or fictional,
and I suppose a possible interpretation
is that he's doing so,
that the fictional author also
happens to be named Borges
but I don't think it's a very
plausible interpretation.
I'll assume a more
straightforward interpretation.
So we have two identities,
the author is the writer,
the one referred to as I
and the writer is Borges,
the one referred to with Borges.
In the story,
the writer tells us of a
number of relationships
that he has to Borges
and compares himself to
Borges in various ways.
These relationships are
perfectly reasonable
and familiar ones to have
to people other than oneself
but some of them are a
bit odd to have to oneself
and some of them are
impossible to have to oneself.
So the writer says he knows
of Borges from the mail
and sees his name on a list of professors
or in a biographical dictionary.
There's nothing mysterious
about one person knowing
about another in such ways.
I know of Barack Obama through
seeing him on television
and reading about him in the newspapers.
That's a reasonable and familiar way
to learn about someone else.
How about Barack Obama himself?
Can he know himself through
seeing himself on television
or reading about himself
in the newspapers?
Presumably, he can and does
learn some things about
himself in that way.
He might learn about a
funny expression he makes
by seeing Obama in the evening news.
He might learn what his exact words were
at a press conference
by reading the transcript the next day
in the New York Times.
But the writer makes it sound
as if he is only aware
of Borges' very existence
through these third person ways
and that would be rather odd.
It would not only be
odd but quite impossible
for Borges to survive the writer,
even if all that's meant by survival
is living on as a literary figure.
If Borges lives on in that
way, so will the writer,
they're one in the same person.
Other contradictions are only implied
as if the writer likes
hourglasses, Stephenson
and the taste of coffee
in a less vain and artificial
way than Borges does.
In following the writer's thoughts,
we must to a certain extent,
pretend that the writer is not Borges
but if we think of it as just
a story about two people,
one of whom reads about the other,
shares some of his tastes,
finds him pompous and annoying
and yet somehow supports him,
it loses its point.
The interest of the story
is the thoughts that the
writer has about himself,
thoughts that are most naturally expressed
in the forms of words usually reserved
for talking about someone else.
The writer is driven to these words
not only because of some fugue state
in which he has forgotten
that he is Borges
but in order to express a
certain alienation he feels
about what certain aspects of himself
and certain achievements of his,
how he feels about them,
aspects and achievements he can convey
by the use of the name Borges.
To understand how Borges' words work,
we need to distinguish
between two kinds of beliefs
or more generally attitudes.
But I'll say, just two kinds of beliefs
our words can express about ourselves
which I call self belief
and belief about the
person you happen to be.
Now, to make these distinctions,
I shift to the second
interesting part of the talk,
an anecdote that Ernst
Mach tells about himself.
So the dean should like
this being a physicist.
Mach, in the analysis
of sensations early on
tells the following story about himself,
"Not long ago," he writes,
"after a trying railway journey by night
"when I was very tired,
"I got into an omnibus
"just as another man
appeared at the other end.
"What a shabby pedagogue that
is that has just entered,
"thought I.
"It was myself, opposite
me hung a large mirror."
Mirrors they have in buses and cable cars
so that when they're crowded,
the conductors can keep track of everyone.
"The physionomy of my class accordingly
"was better known to me than my own."
Now Mach acquired a belief at
the beginning of the episode
that we can imagine him expressing as
one, that man is a shabby pedagogue.
By the end of the episode he has another
which we can imagine him expressing as,
I am a shabby pedagogue.
And just for bookkeeping
and to make it easier to
compare him with Borges,
we'll imagine that he went on
to make an obvious inference and say,
"Mach is a shabby pedagogue."
So we've got three ways of expressing
something that's true if and only if,
a single person, Mach
is a shabby pedagogue.
Two expresses self knowledge
or at least self belief.
While one and three really don't
and yet one and three are,
in a perfectly clear sense,
a case of Mach knowing
something about himself.
For example, we think of one as being true
because Mach implies that he was, in fact,
a shabby pedagogue.
If Mach's being a shabby pedagogue
is what makes one true,
then one was about Mach
and expressed a belief about Mach.
But one is not an
expression of self belief.
One, remember, is that
man is a shabby pedagogue.
Self belief would be, I
am a shabby pedagogue.
Similar remarks apply to three.
I shall say that three and one express
beliefs about the person
Mach happens to be
while two expresses self belief.
To get a bit clearer
about the distinction,
it would be helpful to elaborate
a little on Mach's case
and number three.
Suppose when he gets off the bus,
Mach trips, falls and hits his head.
For a day or two, he has amnesia.
He can't remember his name
or what he does for a living.
He reads the newspaper the next morning
and in the gossip column,
he encounters a story
about a shabby pedagogue
seen on the bus the day before.
"Shabby pedagogue turns out
"to be famous scientist
Ernst Mach," it says.
So Mach comes to have a belief
he would express with three
and that belief was true,
if and only if, the person referred to
by the newspaper as Ernst Mach
is a shabby pedagogue
and he is that person
so in a sense, he comes to
have a belief about himself
but only about the
person he happens to be,
not really a self belief.
But of course, ordinarily,
the beliefs Mach expressed was one
and expresses the next day with three
would be integrated
with the sort of belief
he expressed with two, the I expression,
the I belief, the self belief.
Ordinarily, the beliefs
we pick up about ourselves
by looking in a mirror or
reading something about ourselves
using our own name,
are quickly added to our
stock of self beliefs
but the point is this
really amounts to something,
it's not trivial.
It amounts to more than
the beliefs in question
merely being about us.
We could acquire the beliefs
without, in the intuitive way,
realizing that the beliefs we had
are beliefs about us,
they wouldn't be self beliefs.
And I'm claiming that
when we get back to Borges
this will be a useful distinction
so I'm gonna say more about it.
Here's where the boring part sets in.
For about 20 minutes, if you've got,
if like my cell phone you
have a little bowling game
on there or something.
So this section's called
information games.
Lets start by thinking
bout the function of beliefs
and cognitions in general
and then we'll work our
way back to self beliefs.
Then we'll work our way back to Mach
and then we'll work
our way back to Borges.
It seems pretty clear
that the reason we
perceive and form beliefs,
the reason we perceive,
comma and form beliefs
is to help us guide our actions.
That is if things to right,
we pick up information and perception
that tells us what we have
to do to act successfully.
I mean, there's a lot of other reasons
for believing and perceiving
but one suspects that evolutionarily
that was an important part of it.
What counts as success,
of course, in our actions
depends itself on our
beliefs, desires and needs.
So, for example, a chicken needs seeds
and similar things to survive
and if it hasn't had any food for awhile,
it will be hungry and desire to get some.
It has eyes that are very
good at spotting seeds
and the ability to peck at the
spot where it sees the seeds.
So when it sees a seed,
it's nervous system changes in a way
that causes it to peck
and as a result of this,
it pecks in a spot where there is a seed
if things go right and it gets nutrition.
So information has been
picked up by the chicken
and guided its perception,
not in any way that I want
to suggest is too grand
or resembles human consciousness.
Certainly, it's the sort of thing
that could be done by
robots even some years ago.
But the point is there's a flow
of information into action.
The action succeeds in the circumstance
that the perception is
designed to register.
So this is an example of what
I call an information game.
In an information game,
a system gets information
typically about he world around it
and then uses that information
in the sense that it acts in a way
that will be successful
given the information,
that is given the truth of
the perception or belief.
What characterizes
different information games
is the relations between
the agent and time and place
where the information is picked up
and the agent and time and place
where it is used.
The chicken's game I call
the straight through information game,
the agent, time and place
are pretty much the same
for pick up and use.
I will now illustrate the
strengths of information game.
I see that there's water in the glass
and I drink it.
Now if I'd seen there
was water in the glass,
set it there and ran off
to go to the bathroom
the way men of my age often
have to do and came back,
that wouldn't be the straight
through information game
because I would have to
reidentify it as the same glass.
Searle might have snuck up
and replaced the glass of
water with a glass of...
(laughs)
Chablis, from his vineyard or something,
might not notice the difference.
But people engage in far more
complex information games
than the straight
through information game.
Like many animals, including
chickens I suppose,
we can track moving objects
and accumulate information about them.
I'm really not sure, chickens,
but dogs certainly can.
But here's a human example.
A thief watches me take
money from the ATM.
He picks up the information
that I have cash on me.
Then he tracks me, looking
for an opportune moment
to mug me and take the money.
As he tracks me, he may accumulate
more useful information,
where I put the money,
how fast and strong I
seem to be or not be,
whether I am carrying any weapons.
He accumulates information
about the object he's tracking
and when he strikes,
he uses that accumulation of information
gotten at different times
and brings it to bear on how he acts.
I call a third kind of
information detach and recognize.
It is of great importance in human life,
although probably not uniquely human.
Perhaps rather than tracking me,
the thief merely notes
some identifying characteristics about me,
what I look like,
what I am wearing.
Later in the day in a convenient
dark and secluded spot,
he recognizes me as the person
who took cash from the ATM.
He infers that since I
had a lot of money then,
I still have a significant amount now.
This information motivates his attack.
So he picks up information
about me at one time,
he breaks off his perception of me,
that's what I mean by detach
and then he later uses some of
the information he picked up
to recognize me
and then the other
information he picked up
to guide his action.
He recognizes me because of things
like what I look like
but what guides his action is
his belief that I have money.
Finally and even more
characteristically human
information game, communication.
The thief sees me walking from
the bank down Hamilton Avenue
towards my home.
He phones the confederate
lurking at the corner
of Hamilton and Guinda
and tells him what I look like
and that I am loaded with cash.
This is kind of a typical
Palo Alto example.
I know here in Berkeley,
it seems strange to
worry about such things.
The confederate waits
until he sees a shabby,
gray haired, tweed jacketed pedagogue
and then mugs me.
Information picked up at
one time by one person
is applied that is guides the action
of another person at
another time, communication.
In all these information games,
we can distinguish between two roles.
What I will call the source
and with apologies to those
who actually know some Latin,
the (speaking in foreign language)
of an instance of the game.
The source is the object
information is picked up about.
The (speaking in foreign
language) is the object
the action motivated and
guided by the information
is directed at.
In all of these stories,
I was both the source
and the (speaking in foreign language).
I was the object
the original thief picked
up information about
and the object that was eventually mugged
by one thief or the other.
But clearly things don't always
go as they are supposed to.
The source isn't always the
(speaking in foreign language).
Suppose other gray haired
tweed coated shabby pedagogues
who hadn't been to an ATM
and is in fact quite penniless
makes it to the corner of
Guinda and Hamilton before I do.
The second thief may mug this fellow
and come up penniless.
In this case, I was the source,
the other poor fellow
was the (speaking in foreign language).
The detach and recognize information game
are detached beliefs,
the ones not tied to any
perception have two duties.
They must allow us to
recognize the source,
that is ensure that the source
is the (speaking in foreign language)
and provide information about the source
that will motivate action like mugging.
The thug sees what I look like
which will aid in recognition,
sees that I have cash
which provides motive for doing something
but of course, either can go wrong.
Okay.
Notions, next section's called notions,
files and buffers.
Embedded deeply in folk
psychology and cognitive science
is the idea that our
beliefs, desires and the like
have a structure,
that we have ideas
that are somehow involved in
many different cognitions.
I have beliefs about Stanford,
desires involving Stanford,
conjectures about Stanford,
emotions that concern Stanford.
My idea of Stanford is a
common element of all of those.
Similarly, I believe that
Harvard is a university,
Princeton is a university,
MIT is a university,
and the University of
California - Berkeley
remains the greatest
university in the world
in spite of the very sorry state
of California's budget and so on.
My idea of the property
of being a university
is a common element in all of these.
My belief that Stanford is a university
has a structure,
it involves these two ideas,
of Stanford and of a university.
For my purposes today,
a rather crude taxonomy
of ideas will suffice.
I distinguish between notions,
ideas of things like Stanford
and ideas of properties and relations
which I just call ideas
like my idea of a university.
And among notions, I'll distinguish,
and this is the important thing,
between buffers and files.
A belief involves notions being associated
with various ideas and other notions.
So the basic picture is this,
our beliefs and other cognitions
provide us with two connected databases
which correspond to the
attached and detached
distinction alluded to in the
phrase detach and recognize.
Buffers are basically perceptual.
They are attached to perceptions,
to ways of knowing about
the object in question.
They are of the objects we are perceiving
or at least tracking,
the objects in our hand,
the objects we see,
maybe the people we're
talking to on the phone,
the one we're getting perceptual
information and input about
and are in that sense attached to.
Files are notions we have of objects
that are independent of
any perceptual relations
they may have to us at the moment.
As we navigate around the world,
we are constantly filling up buffers
with information about
objects we perceive,
objects we see and hear,
things we pick up and handle and so forth.
A second database involves files
as a result of previous
encounters now detached.
Links are made between the databases
as we recognize the objects
of which we've formed buffers,
of the very objects of
which we have notions.
Excuse me, as we recognize the objects
of which we have formed buffers
as the very objects of
which we already had notions
or mistakenly think we do.
Here's a striking individual,
an intelligent face,
a kind demeanor,
a strong athlete build.
Who could it be?
Sean Connery, John Searle?
But what would Sean Connery
be doing at my talk?
It must be Searle.
So I have this buffer,
the perceptual information goes in.
After awhile, I sort it out
and attach it to one of my files.
I had a file of John
Searle for I don't know,
since about 1966
when he first read an article by him.
He was probably only 40 or 50 then.
(audience laughs)
Where is John to see how
irritated he's getting.
Oh, there he is.
That's the picture, notions and files,
my head's full of files
and when I go to a new
place or a familiar place,
I'm constant reattaching the files,
that's how life works
and that allows me to bring all the,
when I saw Searle today I said,
"Hi John."
Why?
'Cause I knew his name.
How'd I know his name?
In a better world, we'd just
all have our names right here
but here I have to remember his name,
that is I have to take the detached file
and get it hooked up
with my perceptual buffer
which is also my action buffer.
I know how to say to
someone that I see, hi John.
I'm gonna shift to another friend of mine
named David Israel,
some of you know him
just because that's,
I have some examples worked out
with regard to David Israel
who doesn't seem to have
shown up at the talk,
for goodness sakes
even though Berkeley is his alma mater.
So I know a lot about Israel.
I see Israel on the street.
I say, "Hi David."
I know he used to be obsessed with lists,
he's going to Washington, DC,
hob nobbing with the big wigs,
listening to Dick Cheney
remember the old days
when he was Secretary of Defense
and Al Gore was inventing the internet.
So this is a paragraph I wrote awhile ago.
Information is kind of
piped up from my buffer
to my notion
and from my notion piped down to my buffer
or downloaded or uploaded,
whatever you want to say.
One final piece of information,
now Searle is now occupying
what I call an epistemic role
in my life,
I know that thrills him.
That is I am actually seeing him
which is a way you can pick
up information about people.
Not a lot at this distance
but I can see he's even older and grayer
than last time I saw him.
He's in front of me.
Being in front of is a relation
that is an epistemically
information providing relation.
It's also a pragmatic relation,
that is I could take action on Searle
if I wanted to.
I could run over and
kiss him on the forehead,
I don't particularly intend to do that
but I could do that,
there is a way of doing that.
Now David Kaplan,
who I don't think is in the audience,
he's not in an epistemic
pragmatic relation to me.
I might desire to kiss David
on the forehead right now
more than anything in the world,
I can't do anything about it.
There's no way to just,
from anywhere in the world
kiss David Kaplan on the forehead.
You have to be in a pragmatic relation,
a relation of kissing on the forehead.
So an epistemic role
is one such that when an
object placed in my life,
there's a way of picking up information
bout that object.
I I can find out more about
the person in front of me
by looking at him or her.
I can find out more about
the person I'm talking to
by asking them questions.
I can find out more about
the object I'm handling
by holding it up where I
can see it and so forth.
A pragmatic role is one such that
when an object plays it in my life
I can do things with it or to it.
I can throw the object I'm holding.
I can hit the person in front of me
or shake hands with him
or startle him
by doing something unexpected
like kissing them on the forehead.
Suppose that for some time,
I've wanted to find out the
color of John Searle's eyes.
I have a notion of John Searle.
This means he plays a role in my life.
He's an object at some point perceived
or otherwise gained information.
I've formed a notion of him.
But that role at present,
that role, just being
someone I have a file of
isn't epistemic or pragmatic.
Then here's a person in front of me.
Some insinuated visa vie me
that I can find out the color of his eyes
and tell him how much
I admire intentionality
even after all these years.
But of course, even if he is John Searle
I won't do these things
if I don't recognize him,
if I continue to think that
it's Sean Connery instead.
In a way, and this is an important point,
detached knowledge is inevitably partial.
It's an important point
because detached knowledge
seems to have become the
philosophical ideal of knowledge
but it shouldn't be because it's partial.
The view from nowhere is a partial view.
It's not a deeper, more profound view
than the view from somewhere.
In a way, detached knowledge
is inevitably partial.
It doesn't afford any action.
By itself, it is of no help to us at all,
at least in any very practical way.
If I have a notion of David Israel,
I can think of him.
Maybe I can enjoy making up scenarios
in which he figures.
Imagine David Israel explaining
the structure of lists
to George Bush, for example.
But I wrote a short play about that.
But nothing very practical.
To do something to David Israel
or with David Israel,
you have to get into some relevant
epistemic, pragmatic
relationship with him.
The utility of detached knowledge
is in its potential to augment
the knowledge and object we are perceiving
or at least in a position to act on has.
Related to this is the
concept of know how.
We know how to do things involving objects
to achieve effects conditional
on what the objects are like.
I know how to shake hands
or startle or irritate
or find out more about
the object in front of me
or to my right or in the next room.
I know a lot about David Kaplan
but I don't know how
to shake hands with him
or startle him or irritate him
except in so far as I
get into some epistemic
pragmatic relation with him,
that is I know how to
shake hands with people
who play a certain role in my life
as opposed to knowing how to shake hands
with people per se
or (speaking in foreign language)
or whatever the right phrase is.
Okay.
Now we're headed back to
our targets, self belief.
With all this in mind,
let's return to Mach.
The first thing to observe
is that Mach does play
a very important role
in his own life.
The role we call self.
Ones neighbor is the person
who stands in the relation
living next door to one.
Ones mother is the person who stands
in the relation of
female parent of to one.
These are important roles
but ones self is the person
who stands in the relation
being identical with to one
and it's an even more important role.
Identity is an epistemic
and pragmatic relation.
There are certain ways of
knowing about the person
who is ones self
that don't work for anyone else.
There are certain ways of doing things
to and with yourself
that don't work for anyone else.
There is a way of finding out
if ones vest is linty
that each person can use
to find out about themselves
that doesn't work for anyone else.
When he gets to number two
and says, "Ah, I am the shabby pedagogue,"
he turns his head down
and he says, "My God."
Then there is a way of
getting lint off yourself
that doesn't work with anyone else,
particularly, well nevermind.
As university employees
we've all gone through
sexual harassment training
and we know you just can't go around
doing that to other people with impunity,
even if they're very, very linty.
Methods for finding out whether
a person has a property,
I mean some methods for finding out
whether a person has a property
are what I call normally self informative.
That is, normally if you find out a person
has a property using that method
the person you're finding
out about is yourself.
Just as normally if you find out a person
by opening your eyes while
looking straight ahead,
the person you're finding out about
is the person in front of you.
The method we imagine Mach using
to see if there's lint
on his vest is like this.
Philosophers can invent examples
where the person whose
vest he sees in his way
is not himself.
Perhaps his eyes have been unknown to him
remounted at the top of his head.
So that when he bends down
he sees the vest of the
person in front of him
instead of his own.
And so finds out in the
way one normally finds out
about the lintiness of ones own vest
that that persons vent is linty.
Arguably, some methods
are not just normally
but necessarily self informative.
As ones method for finding
out ones own desires
or whether one is in pain
or whether one likes the
taste of a certain wine.
Now my suggestion about
self belief is this.
We each have what I call a self buffer.
This is the repository of information
picked up in normally informative ways
and it is also the motivator of actions
done in normally self effecting
or self involving ways.
Self belief is belief
involving these buffers
which we can call self notions.
If I was trying to give
an analysis of self belief
instead of merely make the distinction
to work back to Borges,
I would bring in a third
kind of self knowledge
we call primitive self knowledge
which doesn't involve any notion at all
but I won't.
Just in case you were nervous about that.
On the other hand,
we have files of ourself too.
Suppose the day Mach got on the bus
was his first day of classes.
Earlier in the day he
looked at the time schedule
to see when his introductory
physics course met
and in what lecture hall.
He looks for his name in the same way
he might look for someone else's name
if he wanted to attend their lecture.
I say a lecture by a colleague or visitor
or in the same way that someone
else might look for his name
to get to his class on time.
When he sees that he has been assigned
to teach a course that meets at 11 AM
in lecture hall seven,
he picks up information about himself
in the same way he would
pick up information
about anyone else.
Or suppose I need to
call my own cell phone
'cause I've misplaced it
and I want it to ring so I can find it.
Total hypothetical example.
I don't remember my number
so I look in my wife's address book
that has my cell phone number in it.
I find out about my own cell phone number
in the same way I'd find out
somebody else's cell phone number.
In these sorts of cases,
there is no use of normally
self informative methods,
even though we're finding
out about ourselves.
We find out information about ourselves
in this same way we find out
information about others.
When Mach saw what time his class met,
the belief he picked up was about Mach,
the person he happens to be.
It will be integrated with his self notion
with all the information he picks up
about himself in normally
self informative ways.
This is good because
this information has to
motivate him to use normally
self motivated actions
like walking to get to the class.
This is what didn't happen the next day
when he read the paper
and learned that the
famous physicist Ernst Mach
was a shabby pedagogue.
He acquired a belief.
The belief was about himself
but he didn't acquire it
with the normally self informative method
and he didn't integrate it
into that repository for all the beliefs
acquired in that way
and therefore it wasn't a self belief
even though it was a belief about himself,
about the person he happened to be.
When he learned that what
time his class met and where,
Mach had the job of getting
himself to the lecture hall
at the right time.
It is essential for this to happen
that he get this information
into his self notion
for the information oneself notion
that guides ones actions.
Mach knows how to get Mach
someplace by a certain time
because he knows how to get
himself to a certain place
by a certain time.
There is no formula for
getting a certain person,
Freud or Mach or Wittgenstein say,
to lecture hall seven at 11 AM.
What we know how to do
is to get ourselves to a certain place.
A place whose role in
our lives we can identify
the lecture hall upstairs say,
at a time whose role in
our lives we can identify
an hour from now say.
So far then, excuse me while I,
so far then, the idea is
that we have self notions
which are buffers in the sense
that they're tied to epistemic
and pragmatic relations
and a role, the self role,
that's a certain important
individual plays in our lives.
And we also have files of ourselves,
of the person that we happen to be,
that contain information such as our names
and possibly our social security numbers,
telephone numbers, addresses,
office numbers and the like
that connect with publicly
accessible sources of information
from which we can gather
information about ourselves
in the same way that others
gather data about us.
A brief aside,
we can also use these files
to produce effects on ourselves
in ways that are not
normally self effecting.
Hume, frustrated with the
reception of his treatise,
wrote an anonymous and
rather favorable review of it
hoping the positive review
would have a favorable effect
on his book
in the same way of review
of someone else's book
might favorably affect his fortunes.
Or perhaps I break into the dean's office,
sorry about this,
break into the dean's
office late one night,
hack into his computer,
look up my name
and add a few zeros to my salary
and then in a fit of altruism
do the same for Ken Taylor.
So I affect my own salary
and Taylor's salary
in the same way.
But to return to the picture,
we each have a self notion, a buffer,
and a file of ourselves
and clearly they are linked
or they may just be different
aspects of the same,
you can think of it as two manila folders
with a rubber band around them
or as one manila folder
that has different kinds
of information in it.
They're linked.
Most of us know who we are.
There are exceptions like
Mach after he bumped his head.
One might even be wrong about who he is.
Some people think they are Napoleon.
I admire John Searle a lot.
I often fantasize about being him
and approaching life and philosophy
with the intelligence, confidence
and energy that he does.
This is actually sort of true.
What would it be like
to have so much confidence
and energy all the time?
Well anyway,
now maybe as I slip into senility,
these fantasies will give way to delusion
and I'll come to believe I am John Searle
and start showing up for
lectures he's scheduled to give
or the graduate students
in the Stanford lounge
will be arguing about whether Searle
is a closet dualist or not
and I'll say, "I am not a closet dualist,"
and explain why.
But most of us have it
right about who we are
and herein lies a great difference
between self notions and other buffers.
Self notions don't need to be detached.
I can accumulate information
about the person I'm looking at
as I track him through the seminar
or through the party,
I don't know why I'm tracking
him through a seminar,
but when I change my
glance or the party ends
the information my buffer
needs to be detached
either uploaded into a
preexisting file of the person
if I recognize her
or used as a basis for a new file.
But I don't have to do that
with my self notion of my John Perry file.
There's only one person that ever has
the relation of identity to me.
There's only one person
I can ever know about
using those normally
self informative methods.
There's only one person I can ever act on
using these normally
self affected methods.
So if I get it right in the first place,
it doesn't ever have to change.
Once you have the connection right,
it's good for life.
Now the self notion is not
unique in that respect.
I have a buffer for the planet I live on,
the one I find out by looking around.
So far I've never had
to detach and recognize,
it's just always the same one, Earth.
And I have a file for the universe I'm in
and I've certainly
never had to detach that
and I have a file for
the possible world I'm in
and even a name for it, the actual world.
Ken Taylor says,
"If anything is immune to error
through a misidentification
"it's the actual world."
But we're not interested
in those deep topics,
we're interested in I.
Okay, so now we've worked our way
from Borges to Mach to information games
to roles and epistemic relations
and pragmatic relations
and then back to self notions
and the identity is an
epistemic and pragmatic relation
and now we're going back to Borges.
So remember we've got the writer
who identifies himself as I.
We've got Borges,
that is the person the
writer identifies as Borges
and then we've got Borges himself
who wrote the whole thing.
They're all three the same
but different ways of thinking of them.
The writer refers to himself in two ways,
in the third person and in the first
with Borges, the name Borges
and with the pronoun I.
He manages thereby to convey
somewhat different thoughts to us.
With Borges, he conveys
thoughts about himself
tied to his public persona
and information that
he has or could pick up
in third person ways.
With the first person,
he manages to convey
thoughts about himself
tied to information he
gets in self informative
or first person ways.
At least, that's my
hypothesis of what's going on.
What is the connection between
the grammatical categories
of the first and third person
and the distinction between self belief
and belief about the
person one happens to be?
Why do the writers
two different ways of referring to himself
express different thoughts
and have different effects
on us the way that they do
even though they refer to the same person?
The two ways of referring to himself
allow the writer to say things like,
I know of Borges from the mail
which is different from saying
I know of I from the mail
or Borges knows of Borges from the mail.
He's saying something different,
I know of Borges from the mail.
I try to free myself from him.
He can say these things
without seeming to imply the rather odd
I know myself from the mail
or I try to free myself from myself.
Although the last two are
consequences of the first two
given the fact that we know
and without with the
story would have no point,
that Borges is the writer.
So the first statement means
and conveys something quite different
than I know of myself from the mail.
I know of Borges from
the mail is one thing.
I know of myself from
the mail is the other.
Even though these sentences
from the author's pen
seem to have in some sense
the same truth convictions.
Since Borges is the writer,
the first statement is true
if Borges knows of Borges through the mail
and the writer knows of the
writer through the mail.
The second is true
if Borges tries to free Borges from Borges
and the writer tires to free
the writer from the writer
but we do not draw these implications
but find some less meaning
that conveys something
about the writer's thoughts
and how he is alienated
from aspects of himself.
A familiar concept of the
truth conditions of a statement
is simply that it is what has the hold
of the things referred
to in the statement,
the subject matter,
is simply what has the hold
of the things referred
to in the statement,
the subject matter,
for the statement to be true.
I'll call this the subject
matter truth conditions.
Since the truth conditions are the same
but what is conveyed is different,
what is conveyed cannot depend on
or depend only on the subject
matter truth conditions,
that is if I like coffee
and Borges likes coffee
can convey different thoughts to us
but their subject matter
truth conditions are the same,
namely that this guy Borges likes coffee.
There's got to be more to
these thoughts and sentences
than that.
Clearly there's some difference
that is made by the difference
between the first person I
and the name Borges
even though they both refer to Borges.
We can borrow Frege's
term for the difference
between the two co referring expressions,
they are associated with
different modes of presentation.
The terms Borges and the first person I
written by Borges,
both refer to Borges
but the way they do so
and so the way they present
Borges to us is different.
What allows the sentences to
convey quite different thoughts
even though the only
difference between them
consists of which co
referring term was used?
What is this difference?
Those of us old enough to
remember General de Gaulle
or Bob Dole for that matter
will in the case of General de Gaulle
will recall his curious
habit of referring to himself
in the third person.
I don't suppose he did this all the time
but let's imagine that he did.
So you're sitting at a
dinner party with de Gaulle
whom we'll suppose is speaking English
much as we've been ignoring the fact
that Borges wrote in Spanish.
So De Gaulle Says, "De
Gaulle would like some salt."
So you pass him the salt.
You see the deep connection
with John's work on performatives
and speech acts.
There actually is a deep
connection but I digress.
Why does it sound so pompous
when De Gaulle says this
as opposed to just saying,
"I would like the salt."?
The reason, I suggest,
lies in the difference
between the way names work
and the way pronouns like I work.
There are simple conventions
that allow us to refer
to persons with names.
To use my favorite example,
the name David Kaplan,
which is the way of referring
to the famous logician
is a way of referring to the
famous logician David Kaplan.
The same name,
it's my favorite example
'cause he denies this
'cause he thinks you individuate
names by their bearers
but that's really not germane to today
so I won't say anything more about it.
The same name is also a way of referring
to a professor in
Stanford's medical school.
Two different conventions
established at different time
by different parents
that allow us to refer
to two different people
with the name David Kaplan.
And there are lots of other
David Kaplans in the world.
There are more than 1,000
David Kaplans in California.
See, you don't know either
so nobody's really...
Still, we can usually
figure out which conventions
are being exploited,
which David Kaplan is being talked about.
Suppose you were at a dinner
party with David Kaplan.
He's too far from the salt
to reach it and so are you
but you are next to someone who can
and you have discerned that
Kaplan would like the salt
because of his baleful look
in the direction of the salt cellar
after his first bite of steak.
"David Kaplan would like the salt, "
you say to the fellow next to you.
This doesn't sound pompous
but note that it presumes that
the person you are talking to
knows which of the
individuals around the table
is named David Kaplan.
You had an alternative way
of getting the salt passed to Kaplan,
you could've pointed to Kaplan and said,
"He would like the salt."
Which way you said it
would depend on what you
felt you could assume
about your addressee's knowledge,
that is the two ways
of referring to Kaplan
make different cognitive
demands on the listener.
Using Kaplan's name doesn't sound pompous
because you aren't assuming
everyone knows your name.
This is what De Gaulle did
and this accounts, I suggest,
for it sounding pompous,
although in his case, the
assumption was no doubt correct.
So when we plan our utterances
and assess the effect they have,
and what people might learn from them
and what they need to
know to understand them,
it's not just the subject
matter truth conditions,
who we're talking about and
what we're saying about them
that we exploit and need to worry about.
The effect of our utterances
and the thoughts they express
depend on how we refer to things,
not just on the things we refer to.
When Borges refers to himself with I
we think of him in one way,
as the writer of the words we are reading.
To think of Borges as the writer
is to think of him as the one
who's thoughts are being expressed
in the words we read,
that is his current thoughts,
the one that guided the pen as he wrote
or the fingers as he typed.
The name Borges written
by Borges or anyone else
refers to a virtue of conventions
known by all who know him or know of him.
So in using the first person
in referring to his own name,
Borges makes different
cognitive demands on the reader
and we react to those different demands
by interpreting the thoughts
he wishes to convey differently.
He in effect, asks us
to bracket the knowledge
we don't need to use
in understanding the
reference of his words.
When he uses the first person,
we bracket the facts we know
through information we've
accessed through the name Borges.
When he uses Borges,
we bracket the facts we know
in virtue of the user of the name
being the referent of that name.
So he invents two different characters,
one is a writer who is telling us
about his relation to the other,
Borges, a well known author.
These facts about language
and about the difference
between names and pronouns
and especially I,
are a special case of
the general differences
between role based and detached
system of information acts
we considered above.
I is a self affecting way
of referring to a person.
It is a way anyone has
of referring to himself
and it doesn't depend on
knowledge of ones own name
any more than eating the
sandwich in front of one
depends on knowing ones own name.
Borges is a detached way
of referring to Borges.
Anyone can refer to Borges in that way,
whatever role he plays in their lives
and whether or not they
know who plays that role.
I don't know what I meant by that
but that's what it says.
So a first interpretation,
we now have enough materials
for a first pass at an
interpretation of the story
that Borges gave us.
The author is the writer
and has the thoughts the
writer is depicted as having.
The writer and the author
both like maps, hourglasses,
typography and Stephenson
in a way the writer is
depicted as liking them.
The characteristics attributed
to Borges by the writer
liking these things in
a vain way, for example,
are not the ones the author actually has.
They are the ones he would have
if the things attributed
to him by the press,
critics, publicist, were correct.
The works of the author
together with the writings
of critics and the like
have created a public concept or persona
of the author that is not accurate
and yet the author is
constantly exposed to it
in the same way that everyone else is
and cannot avoid it.
The key to this pool of
accurate, semi accurate
and inaccurate depictions of the author
is his name Borges
and so this name is used to
create a character in the story.
We can pretend that the
concept correctly describes
someone real
towards which the writer
feels considerable annoyance.
When the writer tries to do things
and write things that don't
conform to the public persona,
these things are simply absorbed
into the public persona,
interpreted in its light,
changing it but not making it accurate.
He appreciates this concept of himself,
the inaccurate one,
as what will live on
along with his literature.
Only by being the person
that this concept inaccurately portrays
will he continue to be known to survive.
Thus, the penultimate sentences.
"Years ago I tried to free myself from him
"and went into the
mythology to the suburbs
"to the games with time and infinity
"but these games belong to Borges now
"and I shall have to imagine other things.
"Thus, my life is a flight
and I lose everything
"and everything belongs
to oblivion or to him."
But, unfortunately, the end of
the story if taken seriously
belies this interpretation.
He say, "I do not know which of us
"has written this page."
If the character Borges
is simply the author's
personification for literary effect
of an inaccurate concept of the writer,
how could there be any possibility
of Borges having written the page
that didn't involve the
writer writing the page?
How are we to interpret
that last sentence?
It seems to open the door
for a somewhat different
interpretation of the story.
The writer and Borges are
both real, both agents,
different aspects of selves of the author.
So it makes some sense to attribute agency
to one and not the other for some things
and the other and not the one for others.
But what sense can we make
of such multiple selves
and bifurcated agency
with a single person?
Well, I'll say a little bit about that
and then I'll be done.
So this section is called Borges' Selves.
I think selves are basically just people
seen as playing the
role of the same person
as the subject of some verb,
the agent of some activity,
the thinker of some thought,
the possessor of some
emotion and so forth.
My neighbor is just a person
who thought he was playing the role
of the one who lives next to me.
My father is just a person
who plays a role of
being the male parent of,
relative to me,
neighboring father are
role words and so is self.
On this conception of selves,
there's only one self per person
and the person himself or herself is it.
Still, we often use
phrases like the true self
or the authentic self.
Last year or so, Mel Gibson,
arrested for drunk driving,
made a number of antisemitic remarks
to the police person
who was arresting him.
People debate, was that
Gibson's true self emerging
in the uninhibited state
produced by his drunkenness
or his his true self the one
that emerged when he sobered up
and with all of his cognitive
faculties functioning
was ashamed of what he had said?
Without taking sides
on the real Mel Gibson
or even committing yourself to the idea
that some selves are more
authentic than others,
I want to see what sense we can make
of the idea of one person
having multiple selves.
What I will suggest uses the concept
of a motivating cognitive complex.
We begin with the familiar idea
that actions are motivated
by beliefs and desires.
If I intentionally do A,
there will be some combination
of beliefs and desires
that plays two important
roles in my doing A.
First, the beliefs and desires are what,
the beliefs and desires
are what cause me to do A.
Second, the contents of
the beliefs and desires
rationalize in a relatively
weak sense of rationalize
my doing A.
Now, it's clear you can have
different motivating complexes
affecting what you're
doing at different times,
different roles you play
kind of take over your life
but it can also,
the competition can be
synchronic as well as diachronic.
Consider getting out of bed.
One motivating complex has
control of my thought processes.
They rationally go over
what is best for me to do
and determine that it
would be a really good idea
to move my arms and legs and torso
in such a way as to bring it about
that I get out of bed.
But nothing happens.
On my diagnosis,
the cognitive complex that
controls my deliberation
doesn't control my torso.
That's controlled by another live reason,
one that says, "Good to
stay in bed, don't move,"
"or procrastination,"
but I won't go into that.
So as a child, I was
imbued with many opinions
that in retrospect I don't accept.
Growing up in Lincoln, Nebraska,
I was taught by my father and grandfather
that Roosevelt was a demon
as were most democrats,
that there was
something innately special
about Nebraska football,
that the supposed superiority
of places like Harvard and
Yale over our local university
was a matter of snobism
of wealthy patricians.
I think all of these cognitive structures,
they no longer represent my true beliefs
or really beliefs that I'll
live a shadowy half life
in the recesses of the
darker regions of my psyche.
When tired and annoyed
during those parts of my life
spent with people of a
certain patrician caste
who don't know or care where Nebraska is,
the kind of people you meet
that think that Chicago is
halfway between New York
and San Francisco
and kind of have never completely unfolded
a map of the US
to discover Texas,
Oklahoma, Kansas, Nebraska,
North and South Dakota,
at a bar with people
like this late at night,
these subterranean near beliefs
briefly seize control of my thoughts,
although not usually my mouth.
Perhaps if I were as
drunk as Mel Gibson was,
I would find myself
complaining about Roosevelt
and the New Deal and democrats.
And I don't know, I was at
a department meeting once
and of course, not all of you
have ever been Nancy
Cartwright's colleague
but I found myself saying rude
things to Nancy Cartwright
while my consciousness
was totally in the control
of a much saner individual
saying, "Shut up, you fool."
So it happens.
So motivating complexes may be embedded
in larger structures of
belief about ones self
and ones situation,
desires and aspirations,
intentions and plans.
They do not form a coherent whole
and different complexes seize control
of different ways of acting
in various situations and moods.
Borges in the story
is not simply on this
second interpretation
of personification of an
inaccurate public persona,
but one part of a not totally coherent
and integrated self concept, self notion.
In certain moods,
the author is Borges, the
public persona coincides
with a subset of the author's
psyche that has control.
At such times, the
author really does become
a bit of an actor (speaking
in foreign language)
writing and publishing things,
giving interviews and talks
that strike him in other moods
as alien and pompous,
though not without interest and value.
Perhaps in productive authorial moods,
the self conception that one has control
when he walks in the
streets of Buenos Aires,
anonymous, unaffected,
unmotivated by larger ambitions,
can control only an inner
voice that says things like,
"You're being a pompous ass,"
or some more sophisticated
Borgesian version
of such a thought.
So interpreted there is
in some reasonable sense
two selves corresponding to the
two characters in the story,
corresponding to two self conceptions,
two overlapping but differently
significant complexes
of desires, ambitions and intentions
both belonging in some way
to the same self notion
that Borges finds within himself,
each taking control in turn
as mood and situation change
and energy and ambition ebb and flow.
If so, the answer to the question
posed by the last sentence
would probably be Borges.
The writer may have
originally had the thoughts
the story tells us about
but somebody had to write them
down, edit them, polish them
and arranged for them to be published
or we never would've seen them.
This seems like the sort
of thing that Borges
and not the writer
would take the time and effort to do.
That is, it's the sort
of thing that the author,
under the influence of his
authorial cognitive complex
would do.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)